estamos en este hospital Militar detrás
de mí justo donde están recibiendo
atención los cuatro niños que fueron
encontrados ayer después de 40 días en
la selva después de sobrevivir también a
un accidente de avioneta donde murió su
madre y otros dos adultos una historia
sin duda de película que ha tenido una
conferencia de prensa liderada por el
ministro de defensa Iván Velázquez
también le ha acompañado la directora de
bienestar familiar muy presente durante
todo el rescate Astrid Cáceres y ha
habido representación también de los
servicios médicos de este hospital
Militar han dicho que la condición de
los niños es aceptable que no corren
peligro sus vidas pero que Todavía
siguen muy débiles también han querido
lanzar varios mensajes clave como que
nunca ha habido una operación como esta
en Colombia también han dicho que ha
sido muy importante la unión entre
indígenas y militares y por último han
querido des tacar que este es un mensaje
de Esperanza para toda la infancia
colombiana Y qué se sabe Luis acerca del
futuro de los niños
sí los niños nos han contado de esos que
están muy débiles pero que están alegres
Y eso es una alegría que la directora
del bienestar familiar ha dicho que debe
impregnar a Colombia los niños ya están
pidiendo libros no hablan mucho también
han pedido como sus comidas favoritas
uno de ellos El de cuatro años cinco
años que cumplió Precisamente en la
selva pedido papa con pollo y chorizo y
hablando de cumpleaños tanto el menor
cumplió un año en la selva como el de
cinco años la directora también ha
emplazado al país a celebrar pronto
estos cumpleaños se ha hablado también
de cómo los niños sobrevivieron con
fariña con unos paquetes de comida que
se lanzaron desde los helicópteros la
fariña es como un derivado de la yuca
brava también han hablado de que la
mayor reconoció que se habían encontrado
a Wilson el perro rescatista uno de los
perros perdidos pero que luego los
abandonaron y también la directora de
bienestar familiar ha anunciado que los
cuatro niños los va a proteger Colombia
y les van a ofrecer para el resto de sus
vidas educación gratuita